a small but defiant crowd in burkina
faso's capital wagadugu out to denounce
a government unable to protect its
citizens there's been a rise in attacks
by armed groups linked to al-qaeda and
isil this is a peaceful protest the
government does not want to take place
authorities arrested the organizers of
the march on friday restricted access to
social media and threatened to lock down
parts of the capital
demonstrators see all this as an attempt
to restrict
descent the president was elected by the
people and now they tear gases this
isn't right the security forces are
meant to protect us and our property not
attack us the security forces are
failing us
last year government forces lost control
of border areas in the north and east
last week four french soldiers were
wounded during a joint operation with
burkina faso's military attacks now in
the center of the country are forcing
millions of people to flee towards what
seems like the only safe place the
country's capital
we are frightened at first armed groups
would come after us in the bush but from
one day to another they started
attacking villages
now entire districts are empty
pretty soon they will conquer provinces
if this continues
faced with so many military defeats
president rook mccabre dismissed dozens
of high-ranking soldiers in december
replacing them with younger officers
last week security forces arrested
several soldiers accusing them of
plotting a coup to overthrow the
president
fear frustration and anger is fueling
these protests
despite attempts to stifle the
demonstration
it seems this movement calling itself
save burkina is gaining momentum
nicholas hawk al jazeera